[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen guten abend alles
wichtige vom sport hat später wieder
katja stresow auch von mir einen schönen
guten abend und hier sind unsere themen
des tages
[Musik]
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos der
ukrainische präsident seelen ski fordert
schärfere sanktionen gegen russland
erster kriegsverbrecherprozess in der
ukraine ein russischer soldat wird in
kiew zu lebenslanger haft verurteilt und
großer andrang auf das neue euro ticket
in den ersten stunden werden bundesweit
mehr als
200.000 fahrkarten verkauft
[Musik]
jahrzehntelange gewissheiten die im
westen frieden wohlstand und sicherheit
garantierten werden durch pandemie und
ukraine krieg in frage gestellt bzw über
den haufen geworfen über die
konsequenzen berät die politik und
finanzeliten nach zweijähriger corona
pause beim weltwirtschaftsforum in davos
wie so häufig bei vergangenen gipfeln
das zeigt uns jetzt anne gellinek macht
der ukrainische präsident den anfang
flankiert von den klitschko-brüdern
plötzlich ist der krieg in der ukraine
mitten in davos witali klitschko der
bürgermeister von kiew spielt den
täglichen luftalarm vor den er mit
seinem handy aufgenommen hat wenn wir
jetzt aufgeben sagt sein bruder und ex
boxweltmeister wladimir ist das der
anfang vom ende russland müsse
konsequenzen spüren für diesen krieg
es ist der tag der ukraine auf dem
davoser weltwirtschaftsgipfel zur
eröffnung stehen der applaus für den
ukrainischen präsidenten aus kiew
zugeschaltet redet auch er den
versammelten wirtschaftsführern und
politikern ins gewissen und fordert noch
schärfere sanktionen gegen russland
wir brauchen ein öl-embargo alle
russischen banken müssen blockiert
werden ohne ausnahme sanktionen gegen
den it sektor und der gesamte handel mit
russland muss gestoppt werden solche
maßnahmen würden einen überzeugenden
präzedenzfall schaffen für die kommenden
jahrzehnte
seelands ge spricht mitten im krieg auch
über den wiederaufbau der ukraine und
wünscht sich dass sich regierungen und
die privatwirtschaft möglichst bald
daran beteiligen vielleicht ist das ein
noch eine große anforderung für viele
unternehmerinnen unternehmer da jetzt
wieder komplett zurück zu gehen das land
ist ja im krieg ist wird beschossen
risikolos ist das alles nicht aber
natürlich müssen wir uns damit
beschäftigen und die die vorbereitungen
auch die ersten schritte tun und das tun
länder auch in deutschland soll dabei
sein ob man für den wiederaufbau
tatsächlich eingefrorene vermögen von
russischen oligarchen verwenden könne
blieb zunächst offen es ist bewegung
spürbar hier in davos nach dem
jahrzehntelangen glauben an eine ewig
wachsende wirtschaft hört man nun
stimmen die dem markt neue regeln geben
wollen so kann sich wirtschaftsminister
habig etwa preisabsprachen bei energie
vorstellen und das im mekka des
freihandels in davos
krieg pitt und der klimawandel lassen
das weltwirtschaftsforum neu denken noch
drei tage lang in den schweizer bergen
in die ukraine morgen dauert der krieg
drei monate an und erfordert immer mehr
tote allein bei einem angriff auf einen
ort im norden vergangene woche kamen 87
menschen ums leben sagte der ukrainische
präsident
und er spricht von gefallenen soldaten
was er nur selten tut bis zu 100 seien
es im donbass an einem tag einen
russischen kämpfer hat heute ein gericht
in kiew verurteilt im ersten
kriegsverbrecherprozess seit der
russischen invasion lena sünder bruch
berichtet
auch roh und das geständnis halfen am
ende nicht lebenslang für war die esche
marien der 21 jährige russische soldat
hatte einem ukrainischen zivilisten in
den kopf geschossen es war der erste
kriegsverbrecherprozess seit der
russischen invasion weitere werden
folgen dafür wollen russische exil
journalistin auf spurensuche in der
ukraine sorgen die reporterin julia
padova etwa berichtet für eine
russischsprachige webseite mit sitz in
lettland
manchmal tut es weh zu schreiben weil
ich keine fakten verbergen kann aber
komme ich dafür ins gefängnis
allein die bezeichnung der invasion als
krieg könnte sie in russland mit bis zu
15 jahren gefängnis bezahlen japan will
trotzdem weitermachen das off stahlwerk
in mariupol explosionen kommen hier
jetzt nur noch von kontrollierten minen
sprengungen durch russische soldaten das
weitere schicksal der verteidiger die
sich ergeben haben ist unklar offenbar
ist auch ein austausch mit russischen
gefangenen denkbar heißt es aus dem
russischen außenministerium
in mariupol hat russland den
wochenlangen widerstand gebrochen in der
region bonn jetzt ist das hingegen noch
nicht gelungen
wir sind auf jede entwicklung der
ereignisse vorbereitet wir sind zum
angriff zur verteidigung und wenn nötig
zum rückzug bereit
auf beiden seiten gibt es hohe verluste
weit mehr als zehntausend russische
soldaten sollen schon umgekommen sein
schätzt der britische geheimdienst das
wären mehr als die sowjetunion in zehn
jahren afghanistan krieg verloren hat
ich möchte ihnen zdf heute live
empfehlen im gespräch ein russischer
anwalt der soldaten vertritt die den
einsatz in der ukraine verweigern um
19.30 in der app und auf unseren social
media kanäle
das thema waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine seit wochen steht der kanzler
deswegen in der kritik berlin hatte
zugesagt flugabwehr panzer und
panzerhaubitzen zu liefern aber bislang
geschieht das offenbar nur schleppend
oder gar nicht gestern äußert sich dann
die staatssekretärin aus dem
verteidigungsministerium im zdf es gebe
eine nato vereinbarung keine schützen
oder kampfpanzer westlicher bauart an
die ukraine zu liefern über die
irritationen und fragen die diese
statement auslösen andreas huppert und
mathis feldhoff
sie sind nicht die modernsten aber sie
sind aus dem westen vor gut vier wochen
beginnen die usa 200 schützenpanzer 113
für die ukraine zu verladen die
amerikaner liefern was laut
bundesregierung eigentlich
ausgeschlossen sein sollte es ist eine
einheitliche position nicht nur
innerhalb der bundesregierung sondern
auch innerhalb der westlichen nationen
keine schützenpanzer oder kampfpanzer
westlichen modells zu liefern so erklärt
die ampelkoalition warum der 50 jahre
alte schützenpanzer marder nicht auch
geliefert wird in einem bericht des
verteidigungsministeriums heißt es
nämlich 32 marder könnten zeitnah
instandgesetzt und genutzt werden so ein
medienbericht der sprecher des
verteidigungsministeriums bestätigt
diese bisher nicht kommunizierte nato
position es war ja nicht die rede von
einer formalen übereinkunft oder
ähnliches fakt ist dass das bisher noch
nicht geschehen ist dann können sie
davon ausgehen dass dass die
nato-partner so sehen sonst wäre es ja
kein
widerspruch denn gemeinsam mit den
niederlanden liefert deutschland 12
panzerhaubitzen 2000 an die ukraine
westlicher bauart und das modernste
artilleriegeschütz derzeit weltweit die
opposition ist irritiert damit großer
mehrheit hat der deutsche bundestag
beschlossen dass man waffen zur stärkung
der selbstverteidigung in die ukraine
liefern will auch schwere waffen
explizit da scheint es sich wohl um ihr
ein missverständnis oder eine
verwechslung zu handeln us soldaten
richten weiter panzer für die ukraine
herhalten sich die amerikaner nicht an
die nato verabredung oder gibt es sie
vielleicht es bleiben mehr fragen als
antworten
wir bleiben bei den fragen gehen zu theo
koll nach berlin theo das ist durchaus
widersprüchlich weil man sich
tatsächlich fragt was gilt denn jetzt
ja dass überhaupt eine solche frage
gestellt werden muss ist ja in einer
kriegs in krisensituation an sich schon
ein riesenproblem und dass es hier in
berlin darauf keine klare antwort gibt
es macht es politisch wahrlich nicht
besser wenn es wirklich eine solche nato
absprache gibt ob nun formell oder nicht
dann hätte die bundesregierung das klar
kommunizieren können also den bürgern
deutlich erklären was geht und was nicht
was man politisch und militärisch
militärisch will und was nicht wir haben
ja beispielsweise am wochenende gelernt
dass es dutzende marder schützenpanzer
gibt die instand gesetzt werden könnten
und die der bundeswehr nicht fehlen
würden die aber dennoch nicht geliefert
werden und gleichzeitig werden ja
momentan in idar oberstein ukraine an
modernsten westlichen haubitzen
ausgebildet die die bundesregierung
versprochen hat zu liefern also wenn das
ziel war die russin überlieferungen im
unklaren zu halten dann ist es auch im
politischen berlin gelungen danke für
die einschätzung nach berlin theo koll
wir kommen zur afrika reise des
bundeskanzlers am zweiten tag auf dem
kontinent besucht olaf scholz heute
niger ein binnenstaat in westafrika und
anders als das nachbarland mali gilt
nieder mit seinen knapp 25 millionen
einwohnern als stabiler partner
deutschlands im kampf gegen den
islamistischen terror in der sahel-zone
bundeswehrsoldaten bilden hier auf einem
militärstützpunkt nigrische
spezialkräfte aus mehr erfahren wir von
klaus brodbeck
eine stunde geht es hinaus mit der
militärmaschine ein zweiter nichts der
wüsten eagles 42 grad kämpft ilja
deutsche elitesoldaten bilden hier
nigrische spezialeinheiten im
anti-terror-kampf aus holz besuchern
signal nicht nur estland
das ist hier natürlich deshalb besonders
weil es sich bei diesem land um ein
demokratisches land handelt dass ihr die
sicherheit der eigenen bevölkerung der
region aber auch die sicherheit des
demokratischen prozesses gewährleisten
etwas das uns wichtig sein muss die
mission gilt als vorbild weil beide
partner seit jahren auf augenhöhe
miteinander arbeiten die us-regierung
will die zusammenarbeit mit den
deutschen sogar ausbauen der besuch in
tiller ist auch ein signal an die truppe
der bundeskanzler dank den soldatinnen
und soldaten hier für ihre aufgabe für
ihre leistung und zahlt ihnen respekt
wie fragil die lage in der region ist
zeigt sich im nachbarland mali sollte
nur der russischen gruppe wagner haben
sich in den vergangenen tagen nahe der
hauptstadt bamako festgesetzt das
deutsche engagement soll deswegen
künftig teilweise von niger aus
verfolgen liga auf zudem auf
unterstützung etwa gegen folgen des
klimawandels
besonders wichtig ist aber auch mehr
kooperation im bereich bildung da hat
das land große defizite
die hoffnung auf deutsche hilfe
begleitet den kanzler auf seiner
afrika-reise bei jedem thema auf jeder
station
auf die aussage des us-präsidenten
folgte ein sehr schnelles echo aus
peking bei seinem japan-besuch wurde joe
biden gefragt ob die usa im falle einer
chinesischen invasion in taiwan
militärisch eingreifen würden ja lautete
die antwort china strebt notfalls mit
waffengewalt die wiedervereinigung mit
taiwan an und reagierte heute sehr
deutlich auf den us präsidenten ulf
röller ordnete sein
empfang mit militärischen ehren für
präsident biden die usa sind die
wichtigste schutzmacht japans diacks
amerika japan richtet sich gegen das
mächtige china das den inselstaat taiwan
bedroht mit der idee taiwan würde mit
gewalt eingenommen es nicht akzeptabel
und
dann setzte der us präsident nach denn
er ist nach asien gekommen um chinas
macht zurückzudrängen er weiß um die
sprengkraft seiner worte als er die
frage einer journalistin beantwortet
werden sie teil an auch mit
militärischen mitteln verteidigen ja das
ist die verpflichtungen die wir
eingegangen sind
seit chinas demonstrative rückendeckung
für russland wird präsident ski immer
mehr auch als bedrohung in der region
wahrgenommen
sie strebt die vereinigung mit dem
inselstaat taiwan an notfalls auch mit
gewalt immer häufiger verletzt die
chinesische luftwaffe taiwanesisches
hoheitsgebiet denn für peking taiwan zu
china china macht keine kompromisse wenn
es um seine staatliche integrität geht
niemand sollte die entschlossenheit des
chinesischen volkes unterschätzen seine
souveränität zu verteidigen
in peking sehen sie amerikas eine große
gefahr für ihre sicherheit auch in asien
findet eine zeitenwende stadt die welt
teilt sich auf der einen seite china und
russland und auf der anderen seite
amerika mit seinen verbündeten us
präsident biden hat eine botschaft
seinen verbündeten in asien mitgebracht
amerika stehe bereit
nach angaben der vereinten nationen sind
zum ersten mal weltweit mehr als 100
millionen menschen auf der flucht allein
durch den krieg in der ukraine seien 14
millionen menschen hinzugekommen 6
millionen hätten das land verlassen
auch die andauernde gewalt etwa in
äthiopien burkina faso myanmar oder
afghanistan bringe menschen dazu ihre
heimat zu verlassen so die un
wegen der hohen inflation stellt die
europäische zentralbank eine anhebung
der leitzinsen in aussicht es wäre die
erste seit elf jahren
laut ezb-präsident in lagarde ist eine
erste erhöhung im juli möglich bis ende
september könnten die leitzinsen dann
den negativen bereich verlassen
am schalter am automaten und online
heute ging es überall los mit dem
verkauf der sogenannten 9 euro tickets
die im sommer die bürger von den hohen
energiepreisen entlasten sollen für den
pauschalpreis kann man unbegrenzt in
allen verkehrsverbünden und auf
regionalen bahnverbindungen fahren
fernzüge sind allerdings tabu die
speziellen fahrkarten lassen sich von
juni bis august nutzen was kunden sicher
hoffen und wie lange eine reise vom
süden in den norden mit dem neuen euro
ticket dauern kann das zeigt uns
romanesco war der run war groß auf das 9
euro ticket allein bei der bahn wurden
bis mittags 200.000 stück verkauft vor
allem online aber auch am schalter oder
am automaten wurde heute zugegriffen ich
bin keiner der bahnfahrer auf 49 euro
dann ist eben doch sehr interessant um
hochzufahren die austria in berlin da
ist es für mich ein absolut großer
vorteil weil ich gerade dabei bin ich so
ein bisschen im auto zu enthüllen also
ich hab meine familie in sachsen
besuchen das ist jetzt endlich mal
möglich nämlich bezahlbare ab erster
juni geht es kreuz und quer durch
deutschland allerdings nur im
regionalverkehr
die bahn will über 50 zusätzliche züge
einsetzen weiter reisen sind möglich
aber beschwerlich wer sich von münchen
nach westerland auf sylt auf macht
braucht dafür am ersten geltungstag laut
bahn auskunft 15 stunden und 30 minuten
mit sechs mal umsteigen den stresstest
für den ausflugsverkehr gibt es gleich
am ersten wochenende pfingsten der
fahrgastverband pro bahn rät hotspots
wie die küsten oder alt man den
feiertagen gar nicht erst an zu steuern
es drohe überfüllung ich würde mir
kleine strecken suchen wo ohnehin nicht
so viel los ist und ich würde auch mal
drauf schauen dass ich nur strecken nähe
wo die züge mindestens eine stunde
fahren in den ballungsgebieten machen
sich die anbieter weniger sorgen selbst
bei deutlich mehr nachfrage weil wir
dort ein sehr sehr gutes angebot sowieso
schon haben in deutschland und b weil
wir ja auch durch die cola zeit immer
noch so 20 prozent unter dem liegen was
wir normalerweise an fahrgästen hatten
so hoffen die nahverkehrsanbieter dass
manche autofahrer auf busse und bahn
umsteigt und auch nach den drei monaten
neun euro ticket dabei bleibt
wie gut oder schlecht geht es unserer
erde besonders genau lässt sich das von
oben ausmessen nämlich aus dem all über
den wert der so gewonnenen informationen
sprechen wissenschaftler und politiker
gerade bei einer konferenz in bonn und
so werden die daten erhoben satelliten
tasten die erdoberfläche ab immer wieder
neu und veränderungen können so
dokumentiert werden etwa bei
wassertemperatur luftqualität oder den
pegel der meeresspiegel der klimawandel
zum beispiel lässt sich mit dieser
methode besser verstehen und besser
bekämpfen dort ferber dazu
diesen blick hat astronaut alexander
gerst gehabt und auch diesen überall
künstliches licht der mensch hat die
erde verändert mit sichtbaren folgen
berichtet gast auf der erdbeobachtung
konferenz in bonn
waldbrände zb große taifune
wettersysteme die erschrecken sind wenn
man die von oben sieht dann aber eben
auch langfristige veränderungen sehen
die austragenden gletscher die
zurückweichen das kann man tatsächlich
mit bloßem auge sehen das ist
erschreckend
satelliten erfassen die erde und 4.700
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
diskutieren jetzt auf einladung der
europäischen weltraumorganisation diese
daten wie schnell schmelzen die
gletscher wieviel schadstoffe gibt es
wir fühlen den puls unseres planeten aus
dem weltraum dh aus dem weltraum mit all
diesen sensoren aber auch hört natürlich
besser zu verstehen um zu simulieren wie
die zukunft aussehen wird in der
gegenwart helfen die daten ebenfalls so
konnten beim vulkanausbruch auf la palma
menschen rechtzeitig gewarnt werden
deren häuser weiter bedroht waren daten
die auch die politik nutzt
satellitendaten helfen uns ganz konkret
beim klimaschutz auch bei seiner
umsetzung wir können damit waldbrände
vermeiden und wir können zum beispiel
auch emissionen messen und so wenn es
darum geht dass verschiedene industrien
auch ihre emissionen senken sollen
können wir das in den nächsten jahren
auch sehr gut beobachten in bonn wird
deutlich es gibt bedrohliche
veränderungen auf unserem planeten die
satelliten beobachten sie
und auch heute beschäftigen uns wieder
extreme wetterlagen unter anderem in der
alpenregion da gab es schon unwetter wie
zum beispiel hier in jungholz an der
österreichisch deutschen grenze
hagelkörner so groß wie trauben bilder
wie von einer winterlandschaft straßen
und wiesen komplett weiß da musste
tatsächlich der schneeschipper wieder
ausgepackt werden und auch in
kiefersfelden wurden viele autofahrer
vom starkregen gestoppt
ja wir kommen jetzt zum fußball wir sind
beim sport mit katja stresow bieber und
selena die wörter wie es sie berlin
genau heute antwort die frage geklärt
wer spielt in der kommenden saison
bundesliga erstklassig der hamburger sv
oder doch weiterhin hertha bsc der hsv
hat das 1 0 aus dem relegations hinspiel
im rücken die berliner nach aussage
ihres geschäftsführer fredi bobic wut im
bauch die partie am abend in hamburg für
wen gibt nach unten wer darf demnächst
im oberhaus spielen
relegations-rückspiel und hamburg hat
nach dem sieg in berlin einen vorteil
wir sind mutig wir sind überzeugt ja und
werden alles rein hauen um um alle fans
glücklich zu machen um die stadt
glücklich zu machen warum uns selber
glücklich zu machen bei der hertha
hoffen sie auf seine erfahrungen felix
magath wieder besser gelaunt nachdem am
donnerstag seine gesichtszüge gefroren
hamburg traf und siegte die berliner
trotzdem optimistisch ich bin überzeugt
dass wir auch diesen rückschlag
wegstecken
denn letztendlich ist
viel passiert
wir haben so viele nackenschläge gehabt
und trainer hat richtig gesagt die jungs
kam auch immer wieder zurück heute abend
werden wir sehen wer sich besser schlägt
seit freitag wurde spekuliert heute
bestätigt er in persisch wechselt bei
borussia dortmund vom posten des
technisch technischen direktors auf
denen des cheftrainers und folgt damit
auf marco rose er erhält einen vertrag
bis 2025 ja und manuel neuer bleibt beim
fc bayern münchen der nationaltorhüter
verlängerte die auch schon thomas müller
seinen vertrag beim deutschen
rekordmeister
und das zunächst bis juni 2000 24
und noch zum tennis und den french open
in paris wo andrea petkovic nach zwei
jahren mal wieder die zweite runde
erreicht hat durch einen zweisatzsieg
gegen die französin ozean oder
andrea petkovic ist mit 34 jahren die
drittälteste im teilnehmerfeld gegen die
französin osiander da dominiert die
darmstädterin heute das match und
gewinnt schließlich ohne satzverlust mit
6 zu 4 und 6 2
für die french open halbfinalisten von
2014 stellt paris auch in diesem jahr
wieder eine reise wert zu sein
ist der paris air immer
das wetter beruhigt sich morgen und
details hat gleich christa thoben und um
21 45 das heute journal mit marietta
slomka und einem gespräch mit
wirtschaftsminister habeck das waren die
19 uhr nachrichten am montag danke fürs
zuschauen und wenn sie mögen bis morgen
schön
[Musik]
guten abend das neue gewittertief hat
uns heute mittag erreicht und bringt uns
aktuell schon an seiner kaltfront
gewitter mit unwettergefahr heute nacht
zieht das ganze dann aus dem land
dahinter folgt kühlere luft und das
bedeutet der rest der woche wird
deutlich ruhiger in der ersten
nachthälfte müssen wir aber erst noch
mal aufpassen und zwar zwischen bayern
sachsen bis hinauf zur nordsee und zum
emsland da kann es gewitter geben mit
großem hagel mit sturmböen und auch mit
starkregen von über 25 liter pro
quadratmeter in nur kurzer zeit in der
zweiten nachthälfte zieht das ganze in
richtung osten schwächt sich aber
deutlich ab also bis morgen früh sollten
keine unwetter warnungen mehr nötig sein
ganz im norden und auch im süden regnet
es sich heute nacht so ein bisschen ein
bei 10 bis 16 grad morgen haben wir es
meist mit 15 bis 20 grad zu tun 22 grad
am oberrhein bis 25 grad im osten sind
eher die ausnahme
dazu haben wir morgen häufig einen
wechsel aus sonne und wolken aber ganz
im norden vor allem richtung nordsee da
gibt es noch schauer und kurze gewitter
der wind lebt aus südwest deutlich aus
es gibt man kräftige böen und südlich
der donau da haben wir eben diesen lang
anhaltenden regen die nächsten tage sind
dann neben ein paar schauern deutlich
ruhiger mit großen
temperaturunterschieden zwischen 14 und
25 grad